angels at the coliseum and the first
batter up will be david fletcher
fletcher big game last night as he pulls
this one just beyond the reach of matt
chapman to the wall of left do you say
today didn't you not last night but
today
yes today three-hit game yesterday gets
a double to lead off the game ninth
double the season for fletch so here is
tommy listello digging in he was hitless
in last night's ball game and he drops
down a bunt a good one on the third base
side and the throw to first is in time
to get him so the angels here in the top
of the first inning playing small ball
they get that runner to third base with
one out in
scoring position for mike trout fletch
is able to move over to third and give
it trout a chance to give the angels an
early lead here
towards third chapman's got it off alex
throw home and often allen can't come up
with it safe at the plate
they short hopped him handcuffed him by
a little bit of a bobble and the angels
have a one-nothing lead here in the
first so here's goodwin and the bases
are loaded so lots of trouble here for
chris bassett
there's a shot diving play flip to
second double play
that made up for it
tony kemp headlong dive to his left
grabbed it and they double off rendon
at second bid
here's wren heapho
and he's off to a slow start 133 average
this one toward third base javit has to
come charging in on
the throw pulls olson off so a couple
tough throws in the game here for
chapman a little bit of an issue getting
out of the glove as well angels have
runners at the corners with one out
fletcher will be the next batter
ground ball left side chapman bobbles it
goes to first base and safe at first two
nothing angels
angels with one on the board looking for
more mike trout will be the next batter
[Music]
speed hit beyond the reach of simming
out to the alley and left center field
to the wall rahifa will score being
waved around as fletcher
and he is going to score two rbi double
the angels
make it four nothing boy was that a
rocket you can see those numbers really
show what trout has done against oakland
throughout his career that was a rocket
to the guy sure when that'll bring up
tony kemp four nothing angels
gonna get down for a hit and it's gonna
go all the way to the wall
so canner rounds third cannon is gonna
come in to score
and the azer on the board tony kemp gets
his first rbi of the year
number 26 our son
matt chapman
chapman it's a high drive left field and
that baby's gone
guess who's going to introduce him the
next time they should be very proud they
are
home run number nine for matt chapman
when you're starting to see that power
surface
from matt chapman on a consistent basis
peter middle good launch angle
pack your bags folks
all aboard
next stop
pound time and there are two outs oh and
the count is two balls and one strike to
lauriano for two canning delivers and
ramon hits a soft drive into left center
for a basic kind of a soft line drive
just left and over the head of fletcher
and that'll bring up matt olson who's
struck out and bounced out
[Applause]
this one is ripped right center field
nobody's going to get it
trout picks it up lorianno's being waved
home boreano headed for the plate he's
going to score and it's 4-3
the angels have seen this lead slip away
they're still up by a run but a base hit
here would figure to tie it so we'll see
if andres can get the final outrunners
at first and second
and he got it with a fastball he comes
to an end but double by olsen draws the
a's within a wrong angels maintaining a
lead time butchery is on a relief he'll
face three four five olsen chapman and
canada here in the oakland half of the
eighth inning with the angels up a run
olson shoots it out toward center
makes the catch what a play by trout
jose mota was talking about how well
he's been hitting the ball and driving
in runs in oakland here in this series
right a great defensive play by trout as
well now
good read aggressive read it's one of
those plays if he doesn't make it that's
going to end up being a triple so took
the chance outstanding play by trout
going a little bit to his right left his
feet when diving after it and comes away
to rob olson of maybe extra bases ty
butry liking that blade so one batter
stands in the way of the angel stamp and
they're losing streak we'll see if
butchery can get the final out now
4-3 the angels win it they snap that
losing streak gooby and the halo will
shine tonight